my father and I used to invest in
cryptocurrency actively but after his
demise in 2019 life was not easy
I had to inherit those currencies and
manage it all by myself
and that's how I gradually became a
blockchain Enthusiast hey I'm kanjan
khatri I live in Devas it's a small
place near Indore I am currently working
as a blockchain developer at idea Usher
developer Advocate at crypto naukri and
I am a weapery influencer and have my
own Instagram handle and YouTube channel
under the name the Bitcoin talks I
recently upskilled myself with
professional certified program in
blockchain from IIT kanpur in
collaboration with simply learn my life
has been full of ups and downs after
completing my graduation in software
engineering I started to prepare for the
civil services exam but even after
several years of struggle and dedication
I couldn't make it but that didn't make
me stop there I moved on and simply
learn has been the path maker for me
here
after getting certified from Simply
learns course in blockchain I was well
versed in blockchain and to pursue my
passion I started an Instagram page and
YouTube channel under the name the
Bitcoin talks where I educate and Mentor
people pursuing or wanting to pursue
their careers in blockchain within four
months of starting my page I have 5 000
followers already The Faculty is boosted
my knowledge with real world blockchain
applications in various Industries
moreover there were Learners from
diverse backgrounds which made the life
classes more interactive and insightful
and the knowledge I gain helped me to
propagate it to my Instagram Community
as for my career goes ahead I want to
become an experienced blockchain
developer a smart contract auditor and
meanwhile continued being a webpro
influencer and reached more and more
people on Instagram and YouTube in my
leisure time I love have to spend time
with my family and friends whenever I
get time out of work I get immense Joy
interacting with my Instagram community
even after so many failures in my life I
came out of it like a winner
and upskilling myself which simply learn
was one of my many achievements and I am
sure there are more victories ahead